back here in town the rain snow felt
around the valley the State Department
of Transportation helping get stuck in
stranded drivers off the roads this
morning Ryan Matthey live Ryan's near 2
15 in Summerlin Parkway with that big
impact Ryan
yeah Brian a very busy morning commute
for drivers today battling snow battling
rain sometimes a mix of the two you can
see over my shoulder now it's a very
different scene of the valley than what
it was this morning but that morning
scene becoming more common this winter
and ndot says they've worked around the
clock today to keep the roads cleared
today upcoming on your screen now is
what viewers sent us this morning
they're waking up to some icy conditions
outside and it was a similar view out on
our roads and Dot telling me several
drivers and motorists were assisted this
morning whether that's from spinning off
the road getting stuck on the shoulder
needing extra gas on the road but after
helping them they say attention turns to
keeping the roads themselves cleared
we have Crews that are stationed all
throughout Southern Nevada but primarily
up in Mount Charleston down along
Highway 160 in mountain springs on us-95
and Searchlight and when it snows it's
all hands on deck they're working as
long as it takes to get those roads
cleared and back open
now this weather's seemingly more tamed
than what we've experienced the last
couple of weeks and the energy telling
me they did not see any downed power
lines like we did some in some of our
previous storms that sent some nearby
schools online for nearly a week no
other reports of flooding in the county
either but some residents say this is
not all bad coming up at 4 30. I have
how some people are saying actually all
of this wet weather is actually helping
their business for now reporting live
over the 215 at Summerlin Parkway Ryan
Matthey a news now